[Music]
consider throwing a ball straight into
the air can you predict the motion of
the ball after it leaves your hand sure
that's easy the ball will move upward
until it gets to some highest point then
it'll come back down and land in your
hand again of course that's what happens
and you know this because you have
witnessed events like this countless
times you've been observing the physics
of everyday phenomena your entire life
but suppose we explore a question about
the physics of atoms like what does the
motion of an electron around the nucleus
of a hydrogen atom look like could we
answer that question based on our
experience with everyday physics
definitely not why because the physics
that governs the behavior of systems at
such small scales is much different than
the physics of the macroscopic objects
you see around you all the time the
everyday world you know and love behaves
according to the laws of classical
mechanics but systems on the scale of
atoms behave according to the laws of
quantum mechanics this quantum world
turns out to be a very strange place an
illustration of quantum strangeness is
given by a famous thought experiment
Schrodinger's cat a physicist who
doesn't particularly like cats puts a
cat in a box along with a bomb that has
a 50% chance of blowing up after the lid
is closed until we reopen the lid there
is no way of knowing whether the bomb
exploded or not and thus no way of
knowing if the cat is alive or dead in
quantum physics we could say that before
our observation the cat was in a
superposition state it was neither alive
nor dead but rather in a mixture of both
possibilities with a 50% chance for each
the same sort of thing happens to
physical systems at quantum scales like
an electron orbiting in a hydrogen atom
the electron isn't really orbiting at
all it's sort of everywhere in space all
at once with more of a probability of
being at some places than others and
it's only after we measure its position
that we can pinpoint where it is at that
moment a lot like how we didn't know
whether the cat was alive or dead
until we open the box this brings us to
the strange and beautiful phenomenon of
quantum entanglement suppose that
instead of one cat in a box we have two
cats in two different boxes if we repeat
the schrödinger's cat experiment with
this pair of cats the outcome of the
experiment can be one of four
possibilities either both cats will be
alive or both will be dead or one will
be alive and the other dead or vice
versa
the system of both cats is again in a
superposition state with each outcome
having a 25% chance rather than 50% but
here's the cool thing
quantum mechanics tells us it's possible
to erase the both cats alive and both
cat's dead outcomes from the
superposition state in other words there
can be a two cat system such that the
outcome will always be one cat alive and
the other cat dead the technical term
for this is that the states of the cats
are entangled
but there's something truly mind-blowing
about quantum entanglement if you
prepare the system of two cats in boxes
in this entangled state then move the
boxes to opposite ends of the universe
the outcome of the experiment will still
always be the same one cat will always
come out alive and the other cat will
always end up dead even though which
particular cat lives or dies is
completely undetermined before we
measure the outcome how is this possible
how is it that the states of cats on
opposite sides of the universe can be
entangled in this way they're too far
away to communicate with each other in
time so how do the two bombs always
conspire such that one blows up and the
other doesn't you might be thinking this
is just some theoretical mumbo-jumbo
this sort of thing can't happen in the
real world but it turns out that quantum
entanglement has been confirmed in
real-world lab experiments two subatomic
particles entangled in a superposition
state where if one spins one way then
the other must spin the other way will
do just that
even when there's no way for information
to pass from one particle to the other
indicating which way to spin to obey the
rules of entanglement it's not
surprising then that entanglement is
the core of quantum information science
a growing field studying how to use the
laws of the strange quantum world in our
macroscopic world like in quantum
cryptography so spies can send secure
messages to each other or quantum
computing for cracking secret codes
every day physics may start to look a
bit more like the strange quantum world
quantum teleportation may even progress
so far that one day your cat will escape
to a safer galaxy where there are no
physicists and no boxes
[Music]